. So we've already discussed today that Donald
Trump's actions on just about every issue,
everything we see him do publicly, it's motivated
at least partially by.
Does it hurt him in November or does it help
him in November?
That's the lens through which all of these
decisions are being made about carrying his
mask around, about canceling the huge event
of the Republican National Convention.
All of this stuff is just what's the calculus
in terms of how it affects my election when
it comes to vote by mail?
We just received some stunning new polling
data from Emerson polling.
And if this data doesn't convince you that
Trump knows exactly what he's doing by opposing
vote by mail and confusing vote by mail with
absentee voting as if they're two different
things, this data should convince you that
he knows exactly what he is doing.
Polls subjects were asked in this Emmerson
polling survey who they support, Trump versus
Biden and grouped by whether they plan to
vote in person or vote by mail of those who
plan to vote in person.
Sixty five percent support Trump, and only
32 percent support Joe Biden.
Of those who plan to vote absentee.
76 percent support Joe Biden and only 20 percent
support Donald Trump.
So put it a different way.
Trump leads two to one among voters planning
to vote in person.
And Biden leads almost four to one among people
planning to vote by mail.
This is why Trump opposes vote by mail.
Now, the thing to understand is that this
split between in-person versus vote by mail
is not partizan per say.
It's health related.
Let me explain what I mean.
We know from other polling that Republicans
are roughly half as likely as Democrats to
wear masks all the time when they leave their
House.
I think it was something like roughly 66 to
33 year.
You know, 66 percent of Democrats were wearing
a mask all the time outside their house.
Only 33 percent of Republicans or something
like that.
What this means is Democrats are taking the
pandemic more seriously.
The reason that Biden supporters are way likely
a way more likely to vote by mail is they
are taking the risk of catching coronavirus
more seriously than Republicans.
Now, you could come in and say, well, if there's
more vote by mail open, more Trump supporters
will vote by mail.
If there's less vote by mail open, Biden supporters
will just go and vote in person.
It's all going to shake out evenly.
That's exactly the wrong approach.
That is exactly the mistake that's being made.
In analyzing this, Biden voters are more likely
not to vote at all.
If they can't do it safely, while Trump voters
are more likely to vote in person, if that's
available, if that's all that's available.
So sure, most Biden voters planning to vote
by mail.
If they are told you can't vote by mail, they'll
put a mask on.
They understand the importance.
They'll go and take the risk because they
understand the importance of the election.
But if you believe, as is probably the case,
that there are some Biden supporters who might
not vote at all if they can't vote absentee,
you then try to stop vote by mail altogether,
which is exactly what Donald Trump is doing.
Imagine that if you take some state that could
be close and you restrict, cancel or stop
vote by mail and it dissuades just three percent
of the total electorate from voting.
And imagine that in that three percent who
will say, if I can't vote by mail, I'm not
voting at all.
Imagine that 80 percent of that slice would
have voted for Biden and 20 percent of that
slice would have voted for Donald Trump.
That can flip a state that it literally is
enough to flip a state.
Let's look at Wisconsin in 2016 now.
Trump won Wisconsin in 2016 very narrowly.
Trump won by about twenty two thousand votes
in 2016 and Wisconsin.
If you dissuade three percent from voting,
that's a.
83000 people that you would dissuade from
voting, maybe if you say you have to come
in in person.
If 80 percent of those dissuaded or Biden
supporters and 20 percent of those dissuaded
are Trump supporters, canceling vote by mail
grows Trump's victory by 50000 votes.
Now, the margin was only twenty two thousand.
So understand how a small portion of the electorate,
if it is mostly Biden supporters being dissuaded
from voting, could flip or put a state out
of reach.
Now, this is a hypothetical example with hypothetical
numbers.
The point is blocking vote by mail, even if
it affects a small percentage of total voters
based on this data, it would disproportionately
hit Biden supporters.
And it could turn a state.
So when you combine trying to prevent vote
by mail with kneecapping the post office,
which is what Donald Trump is doing right
now, by having selected one of his donors
to be postmaster general, you can actually
turn states.
And that's why, you know, when we see, OK,
one poll has Biden winning by 15 percent,
it's not going to be 15 percent.
Another poll has Biden winning by 10.
But when you account for the margin of error,
it might only be six if that six becomes three
or four.
By Election Day, if you strategically slow
down the mail in some states and stop vote
by mail in other states, a three or four percent
popular vote, big victory for Joe Biden might
not be enough to actually win electorally
with Hillary.
We know to point to as a or two point eight,
two point to as an Elachi as a popular vote
win was not enough to win electorally because
of 77000 votes in three states.
We could see that again.
And this is why anybody who's looking at the
polling and saying, we got this, we got this,
got Bidens up fifteen.
Biden might only be up six or five when you
account for the margin of error.
And that could very quickly become an Electoral
College loss because of exactly this stuff.
Do not become complacent.
Is the message continue.
We will continue our coverage of this on The
David Pakman Show Instagram page at David
Pakman show.
Follow me on Instagram for my latest Argentinian
food delivery from this weekend.
Got some really great stuff.
And bananas, of course.
Of course.
And bananas.
I'm David Pakman on Instagram.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot.com.